hey guys it's gary vaynerchuk again for
garyvaynerchuk.com
and today i just want to uh you know
make a statement
um so here it goes
i'm a triple z list celebrity so please
stop calling me a celebrity or an
internet celebrity or a b-list celebrity
i've been doing a lot of interviews late
and everyone's like how does it feel to
be a celebrity
guys i'm far from a celebrity i'm a
triple z list
celebrity 99.9 of the people in the
world have
no idea who i am that being said
this is kind of where i think things are
going you know everybody talks about the
stretched eyeballs all these different
platforms
nobody will ever get the television
ratings that they got in the 80s and
that is so sorry and going back further
so
so true as a matter of fact i think the
far majority of people
are going to be triple z list
celebrities as a matter of fact there's
going to be lots of triple z list
celebrities and the ones who actually
are zealous celebrities are going to be
very successful
and very capable because with so many
different platforms
and so many different places for
eyeballs to go today it's hard for
somebody to completely captivate
everybody there's so many niches out
there today that you i really believe a
lot of people are going to be famous
within their own little niche
and that's just the extended way of
where things are going and this is very
important to understand
because that's where advertisers are
going to start making different
decisions
and so you're going to start seeing a
lot of very niche
advertising heavy campaigns for example
wineries and people in the wine trade or
people that have wine accessories they
should be emailing me every day people
that are
into candy should be hitting up ijustine
you know there's
all these different niches out there and
there's going to be these cult like
triple z list celebrities that are going
to be able to help their brands
and carry some weight so as flattered as
i am everybody who's emailing me
interviewing say how does it feel to be
a celebrity
i can only laugh very hard and say you
know what maybe i'm a quadruple
z-list celebrity but i appreciate it i
hope you guys have the best weekend ever
go out and crush it
this bad economy is loaded with
opportunity